alors on va faire le point avec geoffro
Lejeune directeur de la rédaction du JDD
puisque il y a eu de nombreux soutiens
de sa famille notamment Julie qui
embrasse Julie de par Dieu j'embrasse
fort il y a les déclarations de la
ministre de la Culture R abdoumak qui
s'est fait défoncer par Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs elle elle est partie sans
comme ça avec cheveux au vent elle s'est
dit tiens je vais je vais faire la la
justicière blan elle s'est pris un
retour de bâton puisque Emmanuel Macron
l' remise à sa place cons elle avit pas
consulté ou elle elle fait souvent des
sorties sans consulter Emmanuel Macron
il faut qu'elle comprenne ministre de la
culture c'est comme un
malade avant de dire un truc il faut
aller consulter voilà et il faut
consulter le le médecin son médecin
c'est Emmanuel Macron donc il faut
qu'elle arrête de se faire des sorties
comme ça R abdoumak et puis il y a j'ai
un problème avec R abdmak j'ai
l'impression que c'est la ministre de la
Culture que de certaines cultures puis
que je la vois toujours sur France 5
c'est le service public je la vois très
souvent invité nous on l'a invité pas
mal de fois d'ailleurs j'ai eu j'avais
envoyé un message à son conseillerim
Abdou mal je lui dit j'aimerais bien
inviter r Abd Malak alors au début je lu
dis j'aimerais bien inviter r Abd malac
il m'a dit c'est qui je mis c'est Sir
j'ai plus jamais eu de
nouvell donc la ministre de la Culture
petit aparté euh c'est bien d'être
ministre de la Culture mais faut être
ministre de la Culture de tout le monde
donc on peut pas aller sur TMC sur
France 5 sur toutes les chaînes je la
vois partout hein
mais quand on l'invite et T PMP c'est
tous les soirs plus 2 million de
téléspectateurs on pique on tout voilà
donc c'est il faut qu'elle parle à tous
les Français RIM abdulmak à toutes les
cultures donc RIM abdoumak c'est bien
sympa de suivre le président partout
qu'à chaque fois qu'il se déplace la
voie derrière à 1 MRE de porter son
manteau mais un moment elle pourrait
plus utile ici merci allez c'est pas
gagn euh on sera très sympa avec
allez on va faire le point sur cette
affaire de Paro avec geoffro le jeune
c'est parti
[Musique]
rap depuis la sortie d'un numéochochoc
de complément d'enquête consacré à
Gérard de pardieu l'acteur mise en
examen pour viol et agression sexuelle
fait l'objet de nombreux commentaires et
fait même réagir la ministre de la
Culture qui fait honte à la France en
fait cette semaine le musée Grévin où
Gérard de pardieu dispose d'une statue
de cire depuis 1981 a également pris une
grande décision si vous vous rendez au
musée Grévin elle a été retirée alors
pour prendre sa défense sa famille
n'hésite pas aujourd'hui à monter au
créneau notamment dans une tribune du
JDD où elle dénonce une forme de
manipulation ou encore à la télévision
cette chasse à l'homme est est vraiment
dégueulasse quoi soutien de sa famille
déclaration de la ministre de la Culture
statue retirée au musée Grévin on fait
le point sur l'affaire de pardieu ce
soir dans
TPMP merci geoffro le jeune d'être avec
nous rédacteur en chef du JDD le JDD qui
n'a jamais aussi bien marché parant le
directeur de la rédaction du fidd Jef le
jeune qui est avec moi balance ton poste
on se régaler merci d'être là et nous
aussi on adore tu es là et puis en plus
on adore les gens qui cartonnent et
c'est vrai que le JDD n'a jamais aussi
bien marché une fois de
plus les donneurs de leçon nous ont fait
de la pub et t'ont fait de la pub tu
peux leur remercier tu leur enverras une
petite boîte de chocolat à Noël à tous
les donneurs de leçon merci d'être là je
froid c'est la première fois cétait la
première fois que la famille de pard de
Gérard de pardieu s'exprimer au sujet de
tout ce qui se passe sur Gérard et Julie
notamment que que j'adore que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs qui est extraordinaire et
c'est vrai qu'on a on a on l'a senti
très émé qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui comment ça s'est passé
c'est eux qui t'ont contacté en fait euh
moi je me suis intéressé à l'affaire à
peu près au moment de complément
d'enquête parce que je je me suis je
suis fasciné par les meutes en fait le
le le le côté tout le monde se jette sur
une personne jusqu'à avec un acharnement
hallucinant une coordination
hallucinante et et donc j'ai essayé de
joindre Gérard pardu à l'époque
plusieurs fois je le connais pas du tout
jeavais je l'ai jamais vu d'ailleurs de
ma vie et et j'ai pas réussi à le
joindre et j'ai fini par la voir au bout
d'un certain temps et puis j'ai vu si tu
veux quelqu'un de de pourtant c'est
onappelle l'ogre c'est quelqu'un d'assez
fort ça fait 60 ans qu'il est qu'il est
au top dans le cinéma et cetera et
quelqu'un de complètement abattu donc on
a commencé à discuter tout ça moi je
voulait lui proposer une interview il
voulait pas parler et et et en fait
comment c'est venu Julie c'est venu par
c'est venu par les avoc j'ai parlé pas
mal aux avocats et ils ont fini par me
dire qu'il y avait un texte en
préparation Yan moi dont tu parlais tout
à l'heure a parlé chez nous il y a y a
de semaines et et les avocats ont dit il
y a un texte de Julie donc elle a fait
ce texte que j'ai reçu et là on s'est
appelé et et de fil en aiguille on a
discuté donc elle est dans le même état
évidemment puis elle est venue hier soir
chez chez Pascal pro j'étais làuss pasal
pro exactement elle a dénoncé une chasse
à l'homme contre son père regardez je
trouve que c'est cette chasse à l'homme
est vraiment dégueulasse quoi et même si
c'était pas mon père je pense que je le
penserai aussi je trouve ça
hallucinant c'est quand même un homme
qui a une liberté il y en a pas tant que
ça personne n'ose plus rien
dire lui dit les choses dit des choses
vous-même vous disiez dont parfois
vous-même oui moi en tant qu'enfant
évidemment que des fois j'ai honte
alors c'est vrai que elle était elle
était très touchante hein j de par Dieu
hier che chez Pascal pro donc qu'est-ce
pourquoi elle a voulu parler j bah le
texte qu'elle fait ce weekend dans le
JDD si tu veux c'est c'est un peu un cri
du cœur quand tu prends ça dans la
figure euh personne t'écoute tu peux pas
te défendre tu te sens démuni même si
c'est la famille de pardieu et à un
moment donné ils ont eu ils ont eu envie
de dire c'est la fin d'ailleurs de ce
texte ils ont eu envie de dire je t'aime
à leur père leur oncle leur le leur
enfin c'est c'est à leur grand-père
c'est ça qui est c'est ça qui est c'est
c'est il pouvaiit pas le dire autrement
que à l'écrit dans un journal qui allait
pas jeter le texte à la poubelle donc
nous c'est ce qu'on a fait et ensuite
euh ensuite elle a elle a elle savait
qu'il fallait qu'elle le dise aussi à la
télé parce que parce que l'image est
plus forte aujourd'hui que que l'écrit
et donc elle a fait elle a fait cette
émission hier et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est complètement euh sans sans filet
il y a pas de communication derrière il
y a rien moi je suis allé l'accueillir
en bas de de ces news pour la faire
monter sur le plateau et et c'est
quelqu'un qui a pas préparé sa prise de
parole elle sait pas 3 minutes avant ce
qu'elle va dire elle est vraiment à nu
et et et tu vois la douleur d'une fille
ouais et elle comprend pas le rejet
total euh de son père alors que tout le
monde l'idolâtré il y a très peu de
temps
une chasse à l'homme inédite d'un type
qu'on a adoré il y a encore 5 minutes et
que pour l'instant il est radicalement
exclu de cette société parce que quoi il
a la liberté de parler comme il l'entend
est-ce qu'une parole veut dire plus
est-ce que quand il dit des trucs comme
ça ça veut dire qu'il l' fait souvent
non
mais j'ai j'ai vraiment été très
surprise de la violence du rejet de cet
homme qu'on a idolâtré toute sa vie
oui Jacques il y a une très grosse
suspicion sur le montage du complément
d'enquête et en particulier sur la
fameuse phrase concernant la petite
fille alors justement parce que le le le
gros problème aujourd'hui bien sûr la
justice va faire son travail et ça on
vient pas dessus le gros problème et
pourquoi tout le monde a été choqué par
ce compliment d'enquête le le plus
choquant et on l'a tous dit ici c'est
les propos sur la petite fille sur le
cheval ça c'est vraiment personne ici je
le dis et je le répète Gérard est
vraiment quelqu'un que j'aime énormément
il le sait je l'ai voilà souvent c'est
et même ça voilà ça c'est vraiment ce
qui pose
problème et je je je je ne sais pas je
mets ça conditionnel je crois que Gérard
ne se rappelle pas l'avoir dit alors non
seulement Gérard ne se souvient pas de
l'avoir dit mais l'équipe de Yan max il
y avit pas que Yan MOX il y avait aussi
deux personnes minimum qui qui
l'acompagné le cadreur notamment et ils
se sont remémorés cette séquence et ils
sont persuadés alors pas à 100 % mais
dans leur souvenir pour eux c'est à peu
près certain que ils s'exprimaient à
propos d'une femme de 36 ans d'accord ça
n et que pour eux ça n'a rien à voir
avec le moment don vous êtes en train de
nous dire au conditionnel c'est ils
auraient pris cette phrase et ils
auraient illustré euh C donc c'est c'est
cette phrase qu'ils ont prise en
illustration ils auraient mis cette
jeune fille sur ce ce cheval donc c'est
une jeune fille de 10 ans exactement ça
ce serait parce que c'est c'est
vraiment c'est ça qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde je vous
dire je t'ajoute un
trucard pard j'ajoute un truc qui est
important mais je vais pas le dire ce
soir c'est qu'il y a un élément dans ce
qui est dit qui leur fait penser que ça
peut pas être au moment de la petite
fille d'accord donc là il y a une
enquête qui est en train d'être faite
bah il y a une enquête en tous les cas
eux ils aimeraient bien récupérer les
rush et ils aimeraient bien au MO France
2 ou le producteur par parce que dans
cette affaire c'est ça peut ne pas être
la responsabilité de France 2 et là
impossible de l'avir pour le moment
c'est impossible mais le producteur à la
on aimerait c'est incroyable he ce que
là ce so c'est pour tous ceux qui
aimeraient vraiment savoir quelle est la
réalité puisqu'il y a une suspicion
c'est que on est les rush puisque toute
la phrase est en off donc la le Off tu
peux l'utiliser sur n'it pas Tristan
Alex attends et j'ai deuxutres éléments
à
apporter va jamais te répondre on verra
si va va peut-être pas me répondre mais
bon si
eux ils m'interpellent bien dans la rue
c'est évidemment très grave mais surtout
il devrait pouvoir pour éteindre la
polémique puisqu'il y en a une a un
certain nombre de journalistes qui
s'interrogent il faut qu'il diffuse le
vrai in c'est-à-dire à quel moment
Gérard de pardieu dit ça et qu'est-ce
qu'il qui il désigne à ce moment-là